[Music]
alerting is vital to quickly notify you
of any problems in your application
cloud monitoring lets you set up custom
alerting but it's important to set up
alerting correctly
let's go over how you can set up
alerting and then look at some common
mistakes and learn how to avoid them
alerts provide timely awareness of
operational problems in your cloud
applications
so you can resolve the problems quickly
for example you may have a system that's
having higher latency than expected
or your production environment might run
into a resource constraint
here we can see an actual notification
email from an alert based on cpu usage
this email shows key information such as
what triggered the alert
which project it's in and when it
happened
when you create an alerting policy
you'll need to describe the conditions
under which you want to be alerted
and how you want to be notified this
includes identifying the metrics
and values that the alert will trigger
on metrics can come from your google
cloud services such as compute
engine or gke you can also alert on
metrics that come from your uptime
checks or
slos notifications for an alert can be
sent to multiple channels
like email sms or pub sub adding
multiple notification channels
makes sure everyone can be notified no
matter which tools they're using
now let's look at how to avoid some
common mistakes teams make when setting
up alerts
the key to useful alerts is timeliness
some metrics may lag behind
actual usage due to ingestion delays
this means they may not be as useful for
production alerts
for example we can see a few metrics
here that are sampled every 60 seconds
but could take up to 6 hours to actually
report
if you want to alert on these types of
metrics you'd better make sure that you
can tolerate the potential wait time
another common mistake is using the
wrong kinds of metrics and alerts
there are three types of metrics and
five types of data that can be used
and it's important to know when to use
each types of metrics you can use
are gauge metrics where the value
represents a specific instance and time
a common example is measuring cpu
utilization at any point in time
delta metrics where the value measures
the change since it was last recorded
one example would be measuring the
change in requests for an api
and cumulative metrics where the value
increases over time
a great example of this is compute usage
time it's important to read the full
details on each metric and choose the
right ones to match what you need
not every type of metric can use every
type of value in addition
cumulative metrics can't be used for
alerting without first being aggregated
into non-cumulative metrics
it's also important to understand the
two stages of data aggregation
alignment and reduction alignment
aggregates your data within a single
time
series by bucketing unaligned data into
alignment periods
or windows you can then choose different
functions to calculate a single value
aligned to a minute boundary such as sum
average or max
reduction then further aggregates that
data by grouping the data across
labels for example you may align your
latency metric value to hourly buckets
using the maximum value
and then reduced by regional labels that
would give you the maximum latency per
region
for each hour just like the types of
metrics you'll want to make sure that
you're aggregating data in the way that
makes the most sense for what you're
trying to measure
in addition to that here are two best
practices to make sure you follow
first the alignment period should always
be greater than or equal to your metrics
delay time window
otherwise your window might not have any
data in it due to the delay
second make sure you're using multiple
conditions correctly
choosing any means only one condition
needs to be met for your alert
while choosing all means every condition
has to be met
check out the documentation to see more
examples and additional details about
alerting
and metrics
[Music]
you